[Music]
suddenly in big American cities the
homeless seem to be everywhere and
that's not your imagination on any given
night more than a half a million people
sleep outside in this country it's
enough people to fill Yankee Stadium ten
times over they're more homeless people
in America right now than active duty
troops in the US Army in fact if they
almost have their own state it would
have as many people as Wyoming does over
the last two years even as the economy
has grown the homeless population has
grown with it in fact outstripped its
growth who are these people these
hundreds of thousands of people and how
did they get there and why and what are
we doing about it what is this anyway
well the West Coast is the epicenter of
the problem and we said on a producer
Charles cougar on an eight day journey
there to seven states in cities rather
in three states what he found was what
you'd expect but it was still shocking
heroin addicts living along freeways in
Seattle a college town desperately
trying to clear its sidewalk so people
could walk RV dwellers living next to
the richest people in the world tent
cities in one of the poorest places in
California where housing costs are zero
across the West we found places in
America that are almost third-world in
their decay and disorganization in the
chaos often we found homelessness and
rampant drug use in places you would
never expect to see them this is a
complicated problem there's no obvious
solution at least no obvious one
solution one explanation you hear is
that it's a mental health problem and
people say the government contributed to
the crisis when it started discharging
patients from mental hospitals and
shutting those hospitals in 1960s and
there's truth in that clearly it's a
factor but it doesn't explain everything
government estimates that just about 25
percent of our homeless population is
severely mentally ill and that seemed
about right we were struck by how many
of the homeless we talked to were not
mentally ill many were totally coherent
some of them were witty even another
explanation is that sky-high housing
prices in places like California forced
families out of their homes and that can
be a factor too but it's not the overall
answer to the question what's going on
because we found in homelessness in
places where the real estate market had
collapsed the places where apartment
rentals go for just a few hundred bucks
a month where working-class people can
afford to live so really it's question
addiction alcoholism financial problems
healthcare costs housing costs and
family dissolution they're all part of
the cause of homelessness in fact in
every story we listen to at least some
of those factors play the role but it's
still confusing exactly what's going on
so to find out we began in San Francisco
one of the richest places on earth San
Francisco has more billionaires per
capita than any city in the world the
reason will nearby Silicon Valley it's
generated unprecedented wealth
there were several multibillion-dollar
IPOs this year alone but beneath this
wealth is extreme inequality the city of
San Francisco has thousands of homeless
people living on the sidewalks if you've
been there recently you know that that's
true the city has a flourishing drug
scene some of neighborhoods have
open-air heroin markets in broad
daylight
cops do nothing about them so despite
its booming economy San Francisco has
lost its grip on its homeless problem
and it's struggling to provide basic
services here's what we found when we
went there this was the scene outside
our hotel in San Francisco a homeless
man hungry for dinner digging through a
trash can for food the epicenter of
homelessness in San Francisco is the
Tenderloin neighborhood
it's just blocks from tourist
attractions like Union Square and major
thoroughfares like Market Street in the
Tenderloin we saw junkies shooting up in
broad daylight
and homeless people wielding makeshift
knives one threatened to stab our camera
crew because we were filming there in
this video a mother and daughter wait
for a public bus standing just feet from
a drug-addled man who's too intoxicated
to put on his own coat the city has
about 470 intravenous drug users per
square mile one reason so many homeless
congregate in the area is a place called
glide memorial church like the city
around it glide is political and post
Christian back in the 60s it removed its
crosses to be more welcoming this man
was out cold on a sidewalk just blocks
from the church next to him a partially
eaten birthday cake syringes that the
city passes out in water packets that
help addicts cook heroin on the street
how does the city this rich get so dirty
one reason in San Francisco no longer
enforces quality of life citations like
sleeping on the sidewalk or public
urination the city used to use citations
as leverage to get people off the
streets but in 2016 a liberal judge
called Christopher hight flushed all
64,000 outstanding warrants for quality
of life crimes every one from 2011 to
2015 but it's not just quality of life
crimes San Francisco now finds it
difficult to enforce any law
smash-and-grab car thefts are everywhere
a huge problem in San Francisco but cops
make arrests in fewer than 2% of them
police station in the Tenderloin
complained that it's impossible to get
convictions against drug dealers so they
don't even try to enforce the law one
officer told the San Francisco Chronicle
that the police now allow criminals to
operate even when cops know who they are
and what they're up to one consequence
of not enforcing those laws rampant drug
abuse well beyond the Tenderloin we
videotaped this man shooting up heroin
right in front of City Hall in broad
daylight here's a picture of two people
shooting up at Mission Dolores Park a
three-bedroom row house right next to
these junkies currently sells for six
million dollars city officials are well
aware of the problem San Francisco
residents have reported feces and
syringe complaints on nearly every block
of the city former mayor mark Farrell
told local media that even he had
stepped on a used needle once at the
Civic Center Plaza right near downtown
but nothing's changing despite the
reports and the money that San Francisco
spends on cleaning its streets we found
syringes and human feces all over the
city
Sam Bowie isn't the only city that's
lost control not in the country and
certainly not in California tomorrow we
will take you to other parts of that
state and what you see will shock you a
shock does our homeless in America
series continues with new cities each
night this week so don't miss that